say in the film like what am i gonna do
almost when i'm steady and good like
will you know how to write
right when things
are
so
stable
and does life ever even get there but
you know i definitely like to think
that it's going to be even better then i
think
you have to be stable and feel full in
order to give so much of yourself to
your art and so i think if you're just
like constantly depriving yourself and
you're constantly sad then your art
suffers
and a lot of people get like into drugs
and they do this yeah like it's an
excuse for art i've been there i've
tried that and i'm like that doesn't
that's not sustainable it's definitely a
weird thing to like write about your
personal life sometimes but no
it's the only way i think so to do it
and when you write do you think
about someone hearing it seeing it
listening to it or do you write it just
for you never i always write just for me
i knew this i knew this about you
i think the second you start thinking
about how something's going to start
being perceived it just
loses all of its magic and i think
i try to be as vulnerable and honest as
possible in my songs i think that's like
one of the hallmarks of good songwriting
and i think when you're thinking about
how people are going to perceive it it
just makes it so hard to do that it's
anxiety-inducing
so yeah such a relief to hear you say
that yeah
i i'm so inspired by you you have made
the world a better place
and in my heart of hearts i wondered and
secretly hoped that you were having that
insular experience because i think
that's what makes it the most humble
and relatable and universal
olivia thank you so much for your time i
just love you so much olivia rodrigo
driving home to you premieres march 25th
only on disney plus i'm sure everyone
will be watching
[Music]
you